We've now described what we
call the instantaneous velocity
at some time t.
And we talked about it
as a limit as delta t
goes to 0 of the displacement
over the time, which
we wrote as the derivative
of the position function
in terms of i-hat.
Now this derivative, we're
going to use a notation.
We'll just write that as
v of t i-hat, where v of t
is the component of the
instantaneous velocity at time
t.
Now remember, this
is just a symbol.
But we describe this
as the derivative
of the position
function, which I'll
indicate as a function of time.
And that's what we
mean by the component
of the instantaneous velocity.
Now what we would like
to do is ask ourselves,
how does the velocity
change in time,
if the runner is
increasing their velocity?
Well, in general, we'll do
exactly what we did before.
What we'd like to
introduce first
is the concept of the
change in the velocity
delta v, which will describe
as the velocity at time
t plus delta t minus
the velocity at time t.
So what we have in here is
the change-- the component
of the change of the velocity.
And this quantity
is how the velocity
changed in into time interval
between t and t plus delta t.
Remember, this is
very specifically
for this time interval.
Now what we would like to do is
take the same limiting process.
Let's take the limit
as delta t goes
to 0 of this change
in velocity over time.
So we have the limit
as delta t goes to 0
of delta v, delta t, i-hat.
And this quantity
is what we call
the instantaneous acceleration.
Now as before,
what we're doing is
we're plotting the
component of the velocity
as a function of time.
Let's just say, again, that
we have some unusual function.
I'll just draw it like this.
And here's the
picture at time t.
Here is the picture at
time t plus delta t.
This change, delta v over
delta t, this is v at t.
Up here, this is what we mean
by-- let's just-- remember,
we're plotting the velocity
as a function of time v of t
plus delta t and
this quantity here,
which is delta v over delta t.
Again, we can even call
as we said before, we can
call this average acceleration.
But what we're interested
in is that as we
take the limit as delta t goes
to 0, then the slope changes.
You can see.
And we continue this
limiting process,
until we shrink
delta t down to 0.
And that what we
have here is this
is the slope of
the tangent line.
And that's what we call the
instantaneous acceleration.
So if we want to
use a notation, we
don't want to keep on writing
limit delta t goes to 0.
So what we can write is a of t.
It has a component a of t i-hat
and that component of a of t.
This is precisely the derivative
of the velocity function
as a function of time.
And so now we've described the
position vector, the velocity
vector, and the acceleration
vector associated with motion.